HISTORY OF LOOKING AT GUN
FRIENDLY, BOMB FRIENDLY
WEBSITES.
>> Bret: PHIL KEATING ON THE
SCENE.
WE ARE WAITING FOR THIS NEWS
CONFERENCE FROM AUTHORITIES ON
THE SCENE, MULTIPLE FATALITIES
IN THE SCHOOL SHOOTING IN
SOUTHERN FLORIDA.
JOINING US FROM CAPITOL HILL
PETER DOOCY OUTSIDE
WITH THE SENATOR, WHO HASN'T
SPOKEN YET.
PETER.
>> WE ARE INSIDE
OFFICE.
SENATOR RUBIO, THIS HAPPENED IN
YOUR STATE.
WHO HAVE YOU BEEN TALKING TO AND
WHAT HAVE YOU BEEN HEARING?
STICK WE HAVE TALKED TO THE
LOCAL AUTHORITIES IN CHARGE OF
THE INVESTIGATION, THE SHERIFF'S
OFFICE, FIRST RESPONDERS.
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS.
IT'S A TERRIBLE SITUATION.
IT'S GOING TO BE A PRETTY
DRAMATIC CASUALTY NUMBER.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS SOME OF THE
NEXT OF KIN FAMILY HAVE NOT BEEN
NOTIFIED.
I ALSO HOPE PEOPLE RESERVE
JUDGMENT.
I HAVE SEEN A LOT OF PEOPLE ON
TELEVISION TALKING ABOUT WHY
THIS HAPPENED.
THE FACTS OF THE CASE ARE
IMPORTANT.
THE MORE DETAILS THAT BECOME
AVAILABLE, WE WILL HAVE A DEEPER
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHY THESE
THINGS ARE HAPPENING.
IT'S A DAY YOU PRAY WILL NEVER
HAPPEN AND IT'S HAPPENED.
>> THIS IS A SITUATION WHERE
UNLIKE SCHOOL SHOOTINGS 10, 20
YEARS AGO, THERE ARE A LOT OF
PICTURES AND VIDEOS COMING FROM
INSIDE THE SCHOOL.
IS THERE ANYTHING YOU'VE SEEN SO
FAR TODAY THAT HAS STUCK WITH
YOU PARTICULARLY?
>> WE HAD SOME OF THE STUDENTS
INSIDE WERE USING SOCIAL MEDIA
TO DOCUMENT THE MOMENT.
THERE IS ONE IMAGE,
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S IN THE PUBLIC
DOMAIN, SOMEONE WAS INJURED.
NO FACE OR IDENTIFYING FEATURES
BUT PERHAPS ENOUGH FOR A LOVED
ONE TO SEE AND THINK THAT MAYBE
ONE OF THEIR LOVED ONES WHO'S
BEEN IMPACTED BY THIS.
IT'S A TERRIBLE SITUATION.
IT'S AMAZING THE AMOUNT OF
CARNAGE ONE INDIVIDUAL CAN CARRY
OUT IN A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
WELL ORCHESTRATED AND PLANNED.
AS I SAID, IT IS STILL AN ACTIVE
SCENE.
AUTHORITIES ARE STILL WORKING
THROUGH THE SCHOOL TO SEE WHAT
ELSE IS THERE.
I THINK WE WILL LEARN MORE IN
THE NEXT 12 HOURS THAT WILL SHED
MORE LIGHT ON HOW THIS CAN
HAPPEN.
>> WHAT KIND OF UPDATES ARE YOU
GETTING?
DOES THE FBI CALL?
DOES THE GOVERNOR CALL?
>> THE GOVERNOR IS TRAVELING
THERE.
HE WAS OUT OF STATE.
WE HAVE SPOKEN TO LOCAL
AUTHORITIES.
WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THEY ARE
JUST WORKING THEIR WAY THROUGH
THEIR BUILDING RIGHT NOW.
A LOT OF PEOPLE SPECULATING
ABOUT THIS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO WAIT FOR THE
FACTS.
THERE MAY BE MORE ABOUT THIS IN
TERMS OF WHAT THEY FIND ONCE I
GET INSIDE THE BUILDING.
THERE IS A PROTOCOL THEY HAVE TO
FOLLOW TO ENSURE THERE HASN'T
BEEN ANY EXPLOSIVES.
I'M NOT SAYING THERE IS.
I'M SAYING IT'S PROTOCOL THEY
FOLLOW.
IT STILL AN ACTIVE THING.
AND EVIDENCE THEY HAVE TO
GATHER.
THIS IS AN INDIVIDUAL WHO'S
GOING TO BE PROSECUTED.
>> THIS IS A SCHOOL SHOOTING OR
THE INDIVIDUAL SUSPECTED OF
CARRYING IT OUT ESCAPED,
SURVIVED, TAKEN TO HOSPITAL BUT
HE IS IN CUSTODY.
WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN TO THIS
PERSON?
>> OBVIOUSLY IS GOING TO BE
CHARGED WITH A CRIME BUT FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT, THEY WILL WANT TO
KNOW IF ANYONE ELSE WAS INVOLVED
AND WHETHER THERE'S ANY EXISTING
DANGERS.
SOMETIMES THEY BECOME COMPLEX.
THERE MIGHT'VE BEEN AN INCIDENT
THAT HAPPENED BEFOREHAND.
THEY MAY LEARN OTHERS HAVE BEEN
HURT IN THE PROCESS.
THERE'S THINGS LEFT BEHIND THE
COULD BE HARMFUL.
THERE'S A LOT THAT GOES INTO
THIS.
I KNOW PEOPLE ON THE NEWS, I'M
NOT SAYING YOU BUT IN GENERAL,
THEY NEED TO REPORT IN REAL TIME
BUT THERE'S A PROTOCOL.
THE FIRST IS TO PREVENT ANY
FURTHER INJURY AND THE NEXT IS
TO GATHER EVIDENCE BECAUSE THIS
GUYS GOING TO TRIAL AND IT NEEDS
TO BE EVIDENCE PRESENTED IN
ORDER TO GAIN A CONVICTION.
>> BASED ON WHAT YOU'VE SEEN
FROM THE RESPONSE, THERE ARE
PROBABLY A LOT OF STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES WATCHING.
THEY WON'T HAVE SCHOOL FOR THE
NEXT FEW DAYS.
SHOULD THEY FEEL SAFE GOING
BACK?
>> WELL, AS I SAID, WE ARE GOING
TO LEARN MORE ABOUT THE FACTS OF
THE CASE OVER THE NEXT FEW
HOURS.
AS THE PUBLIC BECOMES AWARE OF
THEM, IT WILL SHINE LIGHT ON IT
AND THERE'LL BE LOTS OF
QUESTIONS ASKED.
IN THE INTERIM, I WOULD SAY FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE NOT BEEN HARMED,
THEY ARE GRATEFUL AND HAPPY
THAT'S THE CASE.
FOR THOSE WHO HAVE OR WHO HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED OR THE STUDENTS
WHO HAVEN'T BEEN PHYSICALLY
HARMED BUT WENT THROUGH THIS
EXPERIENCE, WE WANT TO ENSURE
THEY HAVE THE RESOURCES.
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT IN BROWARD
IS PHENOMENAL.
THEY ARE WELL ORGANIZED.
THEY'RE MOBILIZING COUNSELING
EFFORTS THAT EVERYONE IS GOING
TO NEED.
THIS IS NOT THE KIND OF THING
YOU EXPECT WHEN YOU SEND YOUR
KIDS TO SCHOOL.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING PEOPLE EASILY
CONFRONT.
IT'S A DIFFICULT THING.
THE INJURIES ARE DEEPER THAN
JUST THE PHYSICAL ONES.
OUR IMMEDIATE THOUGHTS ARE WITH
THOSE OF LOST LOVED ONES AND
MAYBE HAVE NOT YET BEEN
NOTIFIED.
>> SOME OF YOUR COLLEAGUES ARE
TRYING TO MAKE THIS ABOUT POLICY
AND GUN CONTROL.
IS THIS THE APPROPRIATE TIME?
>> IT'S NOT ONLY BECAUSE PEOPLE
DON'T KNOW HOW THIS HAPPENED.
WHO THIS PERSON IS, WHAT
MOTIVATED THEM, HOW DID THEY GET
A HOLD OF THE WEAPON.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT
BEFORE YOU JUMP TO CONCLUSIONS
THAT THERE'S A LAW WE COULD HAVE
PASSED THAT COULD HAVE PREVENTED
IT.
THERE MAY BE BUT SHOULDN'T WE AT
LEAST KNOW THE FACTS?
WE CAN ALWAYS HAVE THAT DEBATE
BUT IF YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE THE
DEBATE ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR
INCIDENT, YOU SHOULD KNOW THE
FACTS BEFORE YOU RUN OUT AND
PRESCRIBE SOME LAW YOU CLAIM
COULD HAVE PREVENTED IT.
I'VE SEEN A LOT OF THAT ON
TELEVISION.
MAYBE THERE IS A LOT THAT COULD
HAVE PREVENTED THIS INSTANCE BUT
WE DON'T KNOW THAT, AND NEITHER
DO THEY.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY PLANS TO GO
BACK TO FLORIDA SOONER?
>> WE HAVE A VOTE ON AN
IMPORTANT TOPIC ON IMMIGRATION.
WE WILL HAVE TO EVALUATE HOW IT
IS, WHEN WE CAN GET THERE AND
TERMS OF THE SETTING IN PLACE.
I'M SURE WE WILL BE THERE AT
SOME POINT SOON.